au revoir les enfants
bow wow je veux patrons soient prudents
nounours je sais que tu aimes faire la
cuisine mais enfin je n'accroche pas
trop j'ai une retraite formidable peut
tout à l'heure bon les jeunes hop hop
hop hop hop hop et pourvu que nounours
est vraiment une bonne recette
je salue les micros j'adhère pas comme
ça mais vu ce soir vous êtes milby trop
quand vous allez m'aider à faire de la
bonne cuisine et qu'est ce qu'on va
préparer nos noces nous allons réaliser
le gâteau de diallo oui c'est bon extra
vous me direz des nouvelles
allons à la cuisine
wae tion posons d'abord sur la table
tous les ingrédients mon chapeau tu fais
quoi mars
appelez-moi chef tout court mais
donnez-moi toutes les bonnes choses que
je vous ai rapporté voilà chef
vauchrétien chef tout court merci m qui
donc est un livre de cuisine en os nous
livrer chef de cuisine qu'elle a oublié
minuti mon petit ce soir le shass a
produit sa promesse le bas niveau voilà
chers de palu et en flore seul tracas
aux ailes
où elle meurt c'est parfait on mélange à
du miel le coup quel beau pays le pays
de diallo il n'y a pas de poireaux oh
mon dieu
j'oubliais le meilleur c'est le
principal le miel je mélange une
dernière froid là vous pouvez goûter les
enfants mais ne mangeait pas tout ils
n'osent pas c'est petit nom est la bonne
nuit chef à demain c'est délicieux chef
je vous laisse les too bad nuit au
voyons voir
e
oh
[Musique]
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
dans nuit des enfants alors grand chef
[Musique]
extra pas trop cette pub stra
nous voudrons of web non merci nounours
merci bonne nuit les enfants endormis
vous bien sagement et faites de beaux
rêves
faute de bon
fêtes de port
[Musique]